tipo ragazzi benvenuti a questo nuovo
meraviglioso video nella mia stanza
nuova bellissima ho deciso di riportare
dopo un sacco di tempo
belen that perché sono usciti nel mentre
che ho visto non me n'ero accorto sono
usciti dei livelli nuovi yacht altro non
mi ricordo nemmeno dove sono arrivato
perché avevo fatti un sacco qua e qua mi
pare di sì fino a qual è arrivato poi
questi non mi ricordo sinceramente poi
può anche essere ma sicuramente non
avevo fatto inferno flash match vegan
paradise carne testicoli questa è una
volta sicuramente non avevo fatto non
c'è nessuno che gioca sarebbe una
sostando da solo perché voglio giocare
da solo me frega niente non mi ricordano
anche i tasti ma fa niente allora questo
è il personaggio nel caso non lo
ricordiate era meglio non ricordarselo a
questo punto come si lancia la testa non
così come si è quello la perfetto ok a
posto ma serio
ok non avevo sicuramente questa mappa
non l'ho fatta va bene ok
vado avanti e mi sa che mi destreggiati
percio cose c'era la possibilità di
saltare ancora più in alto solo che non
avevo la minima idea devi schiacciare il
tasto al momento giusto che saranno
stata praticare ce la faccio
beh ha messo detto che non ero ragazzina
il checkpoint tutto a posto raga non
vede vorrei farlo online sta roba
sinceramente sarebbe molto curioso però
va bene se volta invito step pietro
pietro c'è dietro ce l'ho visto giorno
però a cascare 18 non sa fare livelli ma
una domanda se finiscono schifosi visti
poco che niente ragazzi diventato è più
insomma che ci penso non siamo pensato
ma se finiscono i pochi il plurale di
poco e pochi se finiscono questi qua che
già sono pochi faceva ridere invece
giampiero non sbagliarla e pignola tutto
ok ragazzi a parte che sono caduti in un
di judo minuscolo sono anche come cechov
boys è bellissimo perché quando prendo
ciò che questo non riesco mai a passarci
mezzo perché poi è vabbè allora dicevo
sbatto la testa di continua e vorrei ma
se continui a fare sono cavoli anche tu
hai zione amica mia e poi comunque
quanto dura scappato ora io credo che
questo gioco sia contro linea è comunque
ho questo presentimento
cos'erano scorre il casello aspetta un
desk ambiguo va bene ce l'ho fatta ce lo
fa grazie a tutti ci ho messo sei anni
però non fa niente divertente c'è
scritto su stecco è tutto meno che
divertente sta roba di vissuto zio ma
state vedendo che tipo di livello sta
diventando no perché secondo me è
impossibile ma fuori rendere così
teoricamente già dovrei fare mamma amica
no infattibile lega e non beveva da
all'indietro è veramente il possiamo o
lancio la testa ad essere un'idea
ok devo andare avanti senza mai fermarmi
poche parole se non ce la farò mai
mamma mia come l'ho scampata note fan ma
anche il resto era una spanna zio fatelo
dire se lo motta ed è questa la
difficile ragazzi che come ho fatto a
farcela veramente non lo so adesso
questa roba mi sembra ancora più
fattibile per ora mai ci siamo ragazzi
mai siamo avviati quindi proviamoci
ragazzi sono quasi alla fine incredibile
ci sono ok era cominciare io non riesco
a saltare di soa devo fare qua c'è la
botta pomilio due ore bene o non è non
oso immaginare come sarà palle testicolo
e 9 carne testicoli scusate ma le stesse
la stessa cosa
bene e non uno schema cagata non posso
tipo andare di sopra tipo hackerare la
mappa in questo modo ma lavora che
tattica e non so se riesco ma ci provo
sarebbe veramente interessante regalerò
cioè volta ce l'ho fatta ce lo fa
proprio lui proprio lui non so neanche
come ho fatto ma ce l'ho fatta bene o
schipa metà livello ma in realtà il
fatto che non so se poi tutta qua ci
arrivano al che parte però volevo fare
questa cosa è una delle più grandi
soddisfazioni del giocatore e rompere il
gioco e questo è questo e sono riuscito
a farlo quindi va bene così mi butto di
sotto spero ci sia subito check point
perché sono pensano e vende vinta così
spero ci sia 51 miss piattello ed è come
non aver preso niente erano ecologici e
poi provvedo è quello di s ce lo fa il
roster gioco va bene direi di farne
un'altra ragazzi prima di concludere ma
devo assolutamente fare prima di tutto
adatto se ma non in ordine prima della
prossima prossimo episodio film flash
carne i testicoli lo fa non si può non
fare carne testicoli da fame alla
miseria complicato e carne se devo
essere sincero un po di terrore melo
incute carne testicoli provvediamo ecco
già livello non me non mi sembra proprio
fermi friends obesi sempre sono dei
capezzoli questi a ben
spesso li per li prendi un torsolo di
mela sono io che sono completamente e
vabbè allora ammassati che dopo non
siamo neanche partiti però la vedo dove
sta checkpoint quanto ci vuole vabbè ma
ho capito non c'è ci vuole un chilometro
non so parlare è lontano km se poi
questo lo dirà erano fuoriusciti
ok è qua invece preferisce una salsiccia
ok ok perché siamo dentro l'ostinata
questo lo stomaco sono i succhi gastrici
cosa c'entrano i testicoli tutto ciò
sembra che per a me penso che il tuo
gioco sia uno di quelli che sembra a
vedersi sembra una cavolata ma apparsi
un disastro certamente un casino passa
roba da poi c'è baculo anche perché
dipende come come roteano gli ostacoli
in maniera incredibile
ok no
madonna che casino facciamo così guarda
perfetto questo volevo adesso non ci
dicono mai però che non alzarsi arrivo
sono ancora vivo non so come però va
bene va bene
ricordatevi questo gioco si può giocare
anche sentissi non c'è gli arti tanto
sei uno zombie game e beffa è per
soprano un posto lancia la testa debbo
lanciate arrivare di lanciare la testa
dei ragazzi bronzo come non era mai
arrivato ragazzi qua tutto con tutto il
corpo che non è male però poi ci sono
schiattato prima quindi magari non fare
europee
ok ok ok potrei che pensa di lanciare la
testa e qua per ci sono le bolle che
esplodono vai il momento mai ora puoi
anche esplodere me ne frega niente cosa
si cucchiaia ai cookie servono per fare
cose che però hanno per picchiare gli
altri che in questo momento non ci sono
quindi non avrebbe senso
però se c'è un giocatore con il quale
sta gareggiando lomeny che è un
grandissimo nice
dov'era il coltellone che ho visto non
c'è più ok ce l'ho fatta ho fatto giro
sono arrivate un po più bill dato a ma
di quale si posso non c'è la mia testa
non ce la farò mai a rompere questo
gioco il mio più grande desiderio non ci
riesco manna
ok è e bambù due anni anche centro
perfetto incredibile mamma mia ragazzi
cara nei testicoli ci ho messo anni ma
ne è valsa la pena le ragazze allora
questo e altri episodi benedetti farò
anche gli altri perché mancano tre sono
molto difficile trovare ma gli farò
perché mi piacciono un sacco presso con
quello qua ragazzi spero vi sia piaciuto
e mi piace anche ai social community
descrizione se ne sono si chiede m come
sempre ci diamo una bella ragazzi
[Musica]